don't talk like one of them you're not
even if you'd like to be
when we think of impressive actor
transformations we usually think about
how many pounds someone shed or gained
in order to look like their character
but what about their voices in reality
changing one's voice to become
unrecognizable on screen
is one of the hardest parts of being an
actor and we're not just talking about
accents here
we're talking about the times when an
actor completely changes the way they
speak
to get totally lost in a role i'm a
sokovian fortune teller
when preparing for the role of wanda
maximoff elizabeth olsen not only had to
change her voice
she had to adopt an entirely made-up
accent olson normally speaks with a very
soft american accent like this
i don't like interacting with strangers
not like i you know
hi hello but wanda is from a fictional
country called sokovia
she worked with a dialect coach to
develop a believable accent
but one that didn't sound quite like
anything else that already existed
the challenging part is that in one
division she has to slip in and out of
the accent because
wanda herself is playing a role of
someone in an american sitcom
i'm married to a man a human one and
tall
harley quinn has one of the most famous
and beloved character voices of all time
which was a huge challenge for the
australian actress margot robbie
robbie normally sounds like this i do
find myself unintentionally behaving
like a character after all
which is the complete opposite of her dc
character i get it
you're really not as complicated as you
think she worked hard with a dialect
coach to nail the trademark
squeaky new york sound and listen to
batman cartoons in order to nail the
voice
to do justice to the character lupita
nyong'o is one of the best actresses
working today
and her performance in jordan peels us
left audiences speechless
in the film she plays two versions of
her character one who has lived a happy
life above ground
and her tethered who has survived in
horrific conditions underground
in creating the haunting voice of her
tethered she looked at a condition
called spasmodic dysphonia in which the
vocal cords involuntarily spasm
nyongo who normally speaks like this no
matter where you're from your dreams are
valid
altered every aspect of her voice to the
point where she is completely
unrecognizable
[Music]
and it was no easy task performing the
voice was exhausting and painful
jackie kennedy had a very unique and
well-documented voice
and natalie portman was terrified to
take on the role because she knew
expectations were going to be sky high
not only did she have to nail her long
island accent she had to get the rhythm
cadence and musicality exactly right oh
i've learned so much listening to you
today while portman usually sounds like
this
she's such an iconic figure she worked
for a very long time with voice coaches
and listened to every recording she
could find of the real jackie o
in order to not only get the accent down
but completely change her speech
patterns too
we will have a procession and i will
walk to the cathedral with the casket
christian bale was the first actor to
decide that he needed to radically
change his voice
in order to play batman and robert
pattinson and
ben affleck though his was altered in
post followed suit
in order for bruce wayne to not be
recognized he has to change his voice
when speaking from underneath the bat
suit
neither bale nor pattinson are american
either
bale is welsh as you can hear here and i
had no idea that that was what it was
going to be
and pattinson is british though you
wouldn't know it from his film roles
it's interesting to see to look at a
culture changing and people changing
bale and pattinson both lower their
voices and add a ton of gravel to make
batman not only unrecognizable but also
very intimidating i'm vengeance
there is probably no voice more famous
in the world than marilyn monroe
and any actress who takes on the part
knows that she is going to be watched
closely by fans to make sure that she
gets it exactly right
for my week with marilyn michelle
williams watched all of marilyn's old
movies and listened to all the
recordings of her she could find
in order to play the iconic bombshell i
sleep in nothing but yardley's lavender
even though william's normal voice
sounds very different
i'm just waiting for the right time and
like a really good bottle of wine and a
really good friend
while many have tried no joker
transformation can quite
beat the genius of heath ledger in the
dark knight ledger is so completely
different in the role that we actually
forgot that the actor was australian
which you might remember from the 90s
classic 10 things i hate about you
it's not every day you find a girl
who'll flash someone to get you out of
detention
for the joker ledger was inspired by tom
waits who has a very famous growl and
was perfect
for the gotham villain if you're good at
something never do it for free
jared leto has gotten a lot of flack
over his own portrayal of the joker but
one thing no one can deny is that he
sounds
nothing like himself when in character
leto usually sounds like a pretty normal
american guy
i brown eyes a different nose different
teeth a different way of walking and
talking
but for the joker his voice is a lot
lower with a lot more growl
a slight lisp and of course his infamous
are you sweet talking to me
tom hardy loves to change his voice for
a role in fact it's always the first
thing he starts with when developing a
character
while he never really sounds like
himself on screen his most dramatic
transformation was definitely vain in
the dark knight rises
while hardy normally sounds like this
you don't want to know
he was inspired by boxing champion
bartley gorman
and actor richard burton when it came to
creating bane he was also motivated by
the fact that bane is in pain at all
times
so he has an older more strained voice
i am the league of shadows
andy circus has made a career out of
completely changing into
amazing characters so much so that we
don't really know what he sounds like
off camera
his most famous role ever is definitely
gollum from the lord of the rings
believe it or not his original
inspiration for the voice came from
watching his cats
and listening to the sounds they made
specifically when they have a fur ball
caught in their throat
that's kind of how the voice started to
that's how the voice started to come out
he knew that gollum's name came from the
involuntary noises he made
and started by trying to understand who
gollum was and letting the voice come
naturally
you don't have any friends nobody likes
you
to play cat on victorious not only did
ariana grande have to dye her hair
bright red
she also had to change her voice in
order to sound younger
she spoke with a higher register and
with a much more chipper cadence
in some bloopers you can hear her
switching back and forth from her bright
poppy cat voice to her normal much
softer new york accented way of speaking
me andre robbie beck and cat whoa i'm
cat
meryl streep can do it all but when it
came to bringing the infamous voice of
margaret thatcher to the big screen
even she was nervous not only did
thatcher have a very
old-school high-class british accent her
entire way of speaking was completely
unique
streep naturally has a very soft melodic
voice that sounds like this
truth is so amorphous and difficult to
nail down whereas thatcher spoke much
lower and with more control
while blowing out her w's along with a
ton of other thatcherisms
we will stand on principle or we will
not stand
at all not only did renee zellweger need
to learn to speak as judy garland
she had to completely retain her voice
in order to sing just like the hollywood
icon too
working with a vocal coach for months
before filming she added a lot of
scratch to her speaking voice
to account for the decades of drinking
smoking and heavy pill use that garland
went through
my husband is making a deal for me renee
actually did a vocal exercise routine to
strengthen specific muscles that would
change the sound of her voice
which normally sounds like this with a
slight texas twain
i don't consider myself a vocalist for
2017 suspiria
tilda swinton so completely transformed
into one of her roles that audiences
didn't even recognize her
that's so easy at my age in fact she
actually tried to hide the fact that she
played the 80 year old german
psychotherapist dr joseph klemperer
but was eventually outed not only did
she have to take on a german accent but
had to convincingly sound like an
elderly man which involved making her
voice raspier
lower and much slower than she usually
does i have a patient that is coming in
five minutes another australian who
rarely speaks with her own voice on
camera is the amazing kate blanchet
what would you like to know her biggest
challenge to date was mastering the
infamous voice of catherine hepburn in
the aviator
hepburn's well-known mid-atlantic accent
was a big challenge for the actress
who studied all her old films and worked
with a coach to nail the sound
volume and rapid pace that hepburn was
so famous for
follow through is everything in golf
just like life
wow these transformations were truly
incredible
and a whole other side of acting that we
never even think about
yeah we will never stop being amazed by
heath ledger as the joker
what about you thanks for watching